[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv pour
ce troisième volet de notre série
consacrée à la forêt du maïdo
[Musique]
je suis avec grégory maillot
organisateurs de la course vélo ron
festival grégory aujourd'hui on va faire
la troisième partie de cette course
voilà sa troisième boucle qui se situe
sur la partie haute du massif du maïdo
et qui nécessitera un bon bagage
technique on ira également à la
rencontre des pompiers pour comprendre
les missions de ces hommes du feu sur ce
site
et puis je vous présenterai également
une personne que tout le monde connaît
ici au maïdo je veux parler bien sûr de
doudou pendant la saison sèche ses
hommes de terrain sont mobilisés 24
heures sur 24
les pompiers protège ce site sensible en
proie à des incendies dévastateurs
on part à leur rencontre
au service départemental d'incendié et
de secours de la réunion ils sont huit
cent soixante sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et 1300 volontaires tous
au quotidien interviennent au secours
d'urgence aux personnes est également à
la protection et à la lutte contre les
incendies pendant la saison sèche de mi
septembre à la fin de l'année les
sapeurs-pompiers sont particulièrement
vigilants au risque d'embrasement sur le
massif du maïdo nous sommes les acteurs
donc de la protection de ce patrimoine
particulièrement vigilants pendant cette
période avec une quantité de moyens qui
sont mis à disposition de cette mission
plus de 70 hommes tous les jours
en plus des effectifs des centres
tron alliés sont dédiés uniquement à
cette mission avec des moyens terrestres
et également avec des moyens aériens
avec des hélicoptères et chaque année
avec un avion bombardier d'eau le
gaschney grégory on en est où là on est
sur la route forestière des tamarins
direction de l'arrivée de la seconde
vous d'accord j'ai vu qu'il y avait pas
mal de kiosques et des et des tables de
pique nique ça veut dire que il y aura
peut-être du monde le jour de la course
le dimanche c'est vrai que c'est le
maïdo un site très prisé des techniques
heures et ça fera une ambiance tour de
france et ils pourront l'acclamer
tous les participants voient ça va être
génial d'accord allez on va sur la
première boucle
[Musique]
le maïdo accueille chaque année 5
millions de visiteurs des randonneurs
des sportifs des familles autour d'un
bon pique nique et pour les accueillir
avec douceur un hôte de choix
doudou rencontre entre le maïdo et cet
homme c'est une grande histoire d'amour
doudou même passionnément ces vastes
espaces et cette forêt des hauts sous le
vent
depuis le mois de juillet avec
l'association maïdo nou lé là ils
mettent en avant dans cette boutique les
valeurs et le savoir-faire du village un
lieu des changes pour découvrir
l'artisanat local et l'accueil
chaleureux et convivial des habitants du
maïdo il ya des gens qui viennent qui
font des petits confitures maison il ya
celui qui fait le miel ses peintures il
ya un échange du tout le monde peut
venir exposer et montrer un peu son
savoir aujourd'hui j'ai l'occasion de
remettre ça en valeur à travers le feu
de bois lé café grillé la convialité les
chansons créoles tout ça là bas j'en
profite à mon âge de deux pots de fer
sapporo transmettre un petit peu quelque
chose qu'on a oublié de nous transmettre
et que nous on a perdu du temps à
revivre notre richesse avant tout pour
vous c'est que nous on est heureux
d'être là le diamant quand je monte ici
le matin c'est j'ai l'impression d'avoir
acheté la propriété d'être d'être beau
dallas comme la maison gars comme chez
moi en ouvrant la fenêtre dans le dos
[Musique]
l'émission se termine merci à grégory de
nous avoir fait découvrir ses beaux
sentiers du maïdo merci à toi michael je
vous donne rendez vous le dimanche 10
avril à trois bassins pour une belle
journée au grand air en famille entre
amis
super merci à toute l'équipe merci à
emmanuel alexandre pour les prises de
vue
vous pourrez retrouver ce programme sur
le facebook de 9 7 4 tv à bientôt
[Musique]